[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning pope
francis has stirred up a long-standing
issue inside the roman catholic church
how to treat same-sex couples in a new
documentary the pope says
gay couples should be allowed to legally
join together in civil unions seth doan
is outside vatican city where that
statement is getting some pushback this
morning
good morning to you seth the pope's got
everybody talking this sounds like a
big big deal
good morning to you gail yes indeed it
is a big deal and a real departure from
his predecessors
this is the first time we've ever heard
a pope support
same-sex civil unions this is a man
the revelations came in a documentary
about francis's papacy
in it francis said homosexuals have a
right to be part of the family
they're children of god what we have to
create is a civil union law
that way they are legally covered it's a
shift from what the church
has been saying this official document
from 2003 opposes gay unions
because they obscure basic moral values
and cause a devaluation of marriage
conservative catholics often criticize
this pope saying he sows confusion
and bishop thomas tobin of providence
rhode island noted
the pope's statement clearly contradicts
what has been long-standing teaching
you have to remember this is not a pope
who is a homophobe father thomas reese
is a senior analyst with religion news
service
looking at church teachings what does
this change for the church
really doesn't change church teaching at
all
what it changes is the church attitude
towards civil law
and what the pope is saying is just like
we don't oppose
civil laws allowing divorce and
remarriage
uh he doesn't oppose civil unions that
would allow
gay couples in fact he supports it
because he feels that their rights need
to be protected
he'd supported civil unions back when he
was bishop of buenos aires as an
alternative to gay marriage
which he has always opposed still
melinda anders of massachusetts who is
married to a woman and has
three kids appreciates this pope's
softening of stance
toward gays and lesbians they're making
progress towards inclusivity
which is it means the world to me
because i am a catholic
[Applause]
lgbtq catholics within the church say
this sends a real message to countries
places where there
are still laws against gay people places
where gay people can be discriminated
against
or killed tony
and as we said at the top it's a big
deal indeed set down in rome for us seth
thank you very much